[Music]
hey everyone
michael here have you been even the
slightest bit of attention to
weird things your uncle post on facebook
you might have noticed a hip new boogie
man in the conspiracy theory world
bill gates the microsoft founder and
second richest person alive has joined
the ranks of the rockefeller family
george soros
the bilderberg group and the illuminati
on the list of shadowy figures people
would like to blame their problems on
and as it currently concerns william
henry gates iii
that problem is covid19 now theories
about gate's involvement in the
coronavirus pandemic come in
all shapes and sizes ranging from so
bizarre we can't even trace their
connection to reality
to actual facts grossly distorted to
seem scarier
rumors include bill gates owns the
patent for sars kovi
ii the virus that causes coven 19. he
does not
bill gates will use a forthcoming
vaccine to secretly implant microchips
in us
he won't and bill gates is trying to
build a global surveillance state as
foretold in the biblical
book of revelation also false but in a
much more complicated way
but what i find interesting about the
people behind these theories those who
posit a shadowy nefarious character that
secretly controls the world with their
wealth and influence
is how they often overlook the real and
scary truth that's out in broad daylight
and the theories swirling around bill
gates are no exception let's find out in
this wisecrack edition on the truth
about bill gates
before we get into it this video is
sponsored by our patrons
and if supporting wisecrack or not
sitting through more ads appeals to you
consider becoming one by clicking right
up here for ad free access
patreon support helps us continue our
mission of entertaining and informing
the world regardless of fluctuations in
ad revenue or the youtube algorithm
sign up now at patreon.comwisecrack or
stick around till the end of the video
to hear more
now to preempt a lot of angry comments
bill gates is not only currently the
second richest man on earth he is also
one of the single most generous people
on the planet in terms of the total
money given away
over the last 25 years bill and his wife
melinda have given over 50 billion
dollars to charity
much of it through the eponymous bill
and melinda gates foundation what's more
gates has pledged to donate the majority
of his 100 billion
estate and upon his death his three
children will each receive a 10 million
dollar inheritance
totaling approximately one thirty third
of one percent of his total net worth
for scale that's like if your parents
had a million dollars and left you
300 bucks to understand how conspiracy
theories often distract us from the very
public not at all secret
bullsh powerful people let's take a look
at one of the most prominent bill gates
conspiracy theories
that he is somehow going to make the
entire human population get the
coronavirus vaccine a disease he
purportedly invented
in order to microchip us all for again
some vague plot to track her walks of
shame to the waffle house
this theory falls into the category of
cherry-picking a few facts to tell a
narrative with only the loosest
relationship to reality
and that reality is a thing called id
2020. id
2020 is a non-profit organization
loosely affiliated with the bill gates
extended universe
while the organization doesn't list the
gates foundation as a partner
it does list microsoft a company that
gates only recently resigned from the
board of ngavi a vaccine advocacy
organization that receives substantial
funding from the gates foundation
id 2020's pitch is pretty simple a legal
identity is increasingly a gateway to
participate in the modern world
and lots of people can't actually
identify themselves
if you're homeless in america and can't
prove who you are with a driver's
license or social security card
getting a job social services or just
participating in society is complicated
if you're living on skid row holding on
to identification in the face of
rainstorms police seizures and theft is
just
really hard now imagine those same
problems but faced by refugees looking
for healthcare or people in the
developing world looking to get a small
business loan
id 2020 wants to fix that with a digital
identity system
it's on the cloud now even though bill
gates does not seem to be directly
involved with id 2020
he has addressed similar issues
surrounding identification
and here's where the theories start as
it turns out
medical records are super important a
constant problem healthcare workers face
the developing world is wondering for
instance
who has and hasn't been inoculated
against polio or measles
and the gates foundation since it would
like to stop children from dying of
preventable diseases
partially funded research into an
infrared tattoo a quantum dot
that could provide a medical record that
can't get destroyed in a flood or lost
under a floorboard
people living in the developed world
might take for granted how
important medical records are but every
time a doctor makes sure you're on
schedule for your shots or checks your
own allergies they need reliable medical
records quantum dot tattoos or otherwise
it's fair to suppose that gates believes
identification is a key hurdle in giving
people medical care
but you can probably already see how
this quickly turns into fodder for
conspiracy theorists
id 2020 quantum dots and vaccines got
amalgamated into a scary theory about
how gates was trying to microchip and
track people in some expansive global
surveillance system
to be perfectly clear bill gates is not
demonically marking people or culling
the population
but here's the troubling thing plenty of
what he actually does funds and believes
is ethically debatable at best and
downright
harmful at worst and this is what makes
the conspiracy theories about him so
frustrating
to figure out why i want to talk to you
about disease eradication
if you watched the decoding bill gates
documentary on netflix you might have
learned about how the man
is committed to valiantly defeating
polio and malaria you know this was this
big
risky thing we were doing to help lead
polio eradication
just a quick definition before we move
on to eradicate a disease means to bring
cases of the disease to zero
everywhere forever meaning unlike mel
gibson's career it's never coming back
smallpox for instance was declared
eradicated in 1980 after a global
vaccination campaign
and while there's a few lab samples left
hasn't been naturally transmitted since
then there's malaria and polio these
diseases suck
malaria kills hundreds of thousands of
people a year and before a global
campaign against polio hundreds of
thousands of people were left paralyzed
from the virus
and here i want to say that i personally
believe that a
bill gates is a smart man who genuinely
believes he's helping the world and b
he might nevertheless be hurting science
and global health policy to show eye i
want to introduce you to dr
erada kochi who is pretty much the bobby
knight of public health
cochi by all accounts is kind of a dick
but he's a dick with a good track record
he ran an extremely successful campaign
against tuberculosis for the who before
leading their charge against malaria in
2006.
kochi had a pension for firing people as
well as angering pharmaceutical
companies and the non-profits he worked
for
obviously among those non-profits was
the gates foundation which had made
malaria eradication a priority in 2007
now eradicating malaria is really hard
stopping smallpox still
no small feat was at least easier
because the virus can only be spread by
humans
so to track down every last case you
only need to track down people the
parasite that causes malaria is a little
harder to track
it spends part of its life in mosquitoes
and part of it in humans so when the
gates foundation announced they were
going to funnel money into eradicating
malaria that is
wiping it off the face of the earth most
public health experts thought it was a
bad idea
it was neither feasible nor safe as
sonia shaw writes in her book
pandemic rather experts including kochi
felt that containing the disease was a
better use of resources
in other words we could spend the money
on drugs mosquito nets insecticides and
other measures to drastically reduce
cases rather than expending endless
resources trying to bring them to zero
amidst the call for malaria eradication
kochi and a memo leaked to the new york
times
complained to his boss that the gates
foundation was having a corrosive effect
on the scientific process
he warned that the influence of the
foundation on global health policy had
dangerous consequences on the
policy-making process in world health
and accused the foundation of only
promoting policies that had been
researched by its own grantees
in one case cochi accused the gates
foundation of pushing a potentially
dangerous malaria drug
a policy that just so happened to be
funded by their own research dollars
dr kochi wrote although it was less and
less straightforward that the health
agency should recommend it the agency's
objections were met with intense and
aggressive opposition from gates-backed
scientists and the foundation
the who he wrote needs to stand up to
such pressures and ensure that the
review of evidence is a rigorously
independent of vested interests
this did not happen instead the who
adopted the gates-backed plan
another health expert amir oteron said
his experience with gates finance policy
groups convinced him they were engaged
in stomach churning groupthink
and what happened to cochi for speaking
out about gates as shaw writes he was
put on gardeningly
never to be heard from again and this is
the not at all secret truth about bill
gates
he's not a secret dictator with a
shadowy agenda instead
he's a very rich person who can throw
his money around to have his voice heard
through his contributions to the who
he's also buying influence over their
policies
he's no different in that way from
michael bloomberg who in his bid for new
york city mayor famously made charitable
donations to groups that were critical
of him to shut them up
or the koch brothers who have spent
millions of dollars advancing their pet
political causes or george soros who was
done similarly on the opposite side of
the political spectrum
you might look at the aims of soros or
gates and call them laudable
and often many of them are but a world
where a select few decide what's good
for the rest of the world
basically amounts to a benevolent
oligarchy and it's not a shadowy cabal
it's just kind of how modern
philanthropy works a ton of non-profit
activity nowadays is directed in some
part by grants from huge organizations
like the rockefeller foundation the
gates foundation
the koch foundation and also corporate
donors looking for good pr
companies like mastercard or starbucks
are more than eager to shell out
millions of dollars to charitable causes
and hey
what's wrong with doing a good deed the
problem like we saw with malaria
is that money often has implicit or
explicit strings attached
the countless health researchers funded
by the gates foundation might for
instance
feel less inclined to criticize the
foundation's policies or its corporate
benefactors
as sociologist lindsay magoy notes the
fact that the gates is often fund
initiatives that many people approve of
should not
insulate them from criticism and to date
that's exactly what has happened
gaping silence the autocratic influence
on the who is just one example
we could also consider what it means for
global health policy to enforce this
top-down model
consider gate's mission to eradicate
polio a seriously cool idea
but the thing is polio has already been
combated so well that it doesn't even
hit the top 10 list of things people in
rural villages are worried about killing
them
donald henderson who led the who's
successful effort to eradicate smallpox
has noted that polio vaccines have come
at the expense of
other more urgent vaccinations henderson
recounts interactions with villagers who
questioned
why they're being inoculated for polio
instead of the much more urgent and
deadly problem of measles
so is bill gates doing apparently noble
things in
all the wrong ways maybe but his undue
influence hasn't
merely refocused public health
priorities at the highest level it's
also led to a lot of other
far shadier policies james love the
director of knowledge ecology
international
argues that gates uses his philanthropy
to push a pro-patent agenda for
pharmaceutical drugs
even in countries that are too poor to
afford many patented drugs it's a
position
widely criticized by the public health
world if drug companies had a little
more leeway to produce generic versions
of life-saving drugs they would be able
to make a dent in the millions of annual
deaths from treatable diseases
and while bill gates recently publicly
argued that a covid19 vaccine needs to
go to those who need it the most
rather than the highest bidder if we
just let drugs and vaccines go to the
highest bidders
instead of to the people and the places
where they're most needed
will have a longer more unjust
deadlier pandemic he has zero interest
in tweaking patent laws against his own
interest
because he built his entire fortune and
continues to grow it with intellectual
property laws that protect microsoft's
profits
mcgoway writes that his opposition may
have single-handedly forwarded efforts
to open pharmaceutical markets to more
generic competition but there's more
mcgoway quotes ngo director james love
who explains that
the gates foundation funds most of the
journalism on this topic
and they have been hardline advocates
for strong patent protection since the
1990s
making an open discussion on the issue
even more difficult
the influence of donors on the
scientific community isn't just limited
to the gates foundation
mcgowey tells the story of david healy a
psychiatrist who was offered a job by
the university of toronto in 2000
he then gave a talk discussing the
limitations of clinical drug trials and
revealing rare side effects
invoking the example of prozac turns out
prozac's manufacturer eli lilly is a
major donor to the university of toronto
and provided over half the funding to
the department healey was supposed to
run
his job offer was retracted a few weeks
later
if one cares about free and open
academic debate one has to ask what kind
of debate gets squashed based on
pressure from donors
and here's the frustrating thing about
conspiracy theorists who see in the
shadows cabals of pharmaceutical reps
attempting mass mind control
if they turn on a lights it's just their
regular old free market
which brings us back to id 2020. it's
worth noting that the stated goal of
id2020 is to create a digital identity
for people that they
individually own they're not proposing
some gross centralized surveillance
system
the truth the real conspiracy if you
will is far
more boring they're building
infrastructure
if you're a multinational corporation
like accenture or microsoft
a big impediment to doing business is
lack of infrastructure in the developing
world
microsoft can't sell xboxes if cities
don't have electricity or internet
accenture can help companies run
data-driven ads if there's no data to
mine
and here is the other quote-unquote
conspiracy of a ton
of corporate philanthropy it's just a
tax-free way to build the infrastructure
your company needs
say you're a mining company looking to
extract minerals in a remote part of
africa
you need to transport supplies in and
minerals out but there's no road
you could just pay for it and mark it as
an expense or you could work through
some charity get a grant from the
government to
improve infrastructure and get the same
road built for practically free
this is just a made-up example but
there's plenty of real ones that magoe
details
where government loans for charitable
causes just act like venture capital on
a risky new business venture
take vodafone a company worth over 80
billion pounds in 2011 which received 1
million in grants from the british
government to launch a mobile payment
system in parts of africa
this system that would go on to become
highly profitable for vodafone and their
subsidiaries
magoey writes while most people would
agree that better mobile access and
services in the developing regions is a
positive development
many would also suggest that vodafone
should incur its own business costs
seeing as the company and its
shareholders have full entitlement to
all profits minus taxes
a similar example lies in microfinance
very small loans meant to help people
lift themselves out of poverty
after raising billions of dollars in
grants contributions in government aid
the real winners of the system are
western investors
who reap billions in profits from loans
with incredibly high interest rates
in this case governments are subsidizing
the risks companies take as they build
up the corporate and physical
infrastructure to see if they can make a
buck
and with partners like mastercard
accenture and microsoft it's not hard to
see why this might be an
added bonus for donating to something
like id 2020.
after all digital ids would function as
well digital infrastructure
laying the groundwork for all kinds of
business to be conducted
even if a person is in control of their
id it would allow them to willingly give
up their information to apply for a
credit card or a micro loan or to sign
away their privacy willingly in some
gargantuan terms of service
and from there mastercard can sell that
information to advertisers and i want to
be careful here because this is the one
claim i'm making that's speculative
but i don't think it's a stretch to say
somewhere down the line there will be a
disagreement in how
id 2020 operates let's say over a
privacy concern
when push comes to shove the people
writing the checks not you
or i or anyone using a digital id in
afghanistan will get to decide which
side wins
unlike a conspiracy theorist i fully
acknowledge that they might actually
establish meaningful privacy protection
and i also know that plenty of
organizations involved in id 2020 really
do just want a better way to provide
health care to people like the gates
funded gavi
there's also the argument that even if
mastercard is itching to sell data
hey at least all that greed might end up
helping some people but one thing we do
know
philanthropy can be incredibly
profitable journalist tim schwab notes
that the gates foundation has sent
millions in charitable contributions to
for-profit companies
some of which the foundation owns stocks
or bonds in companies like merck eli
lilly and pfizer
schwab also notes that despite pledging
to give away millions of dollars
bill gates personal net worth continues
to grow in 2006 he was worth 50 billion
today he's worth 118 billion and while
gates hasn't profited directly from his
foundation
it's clear promotes policies that
protect his own financial interests
of course the obvious answer to all this
is it's his money he can do what he
wants
and yes this is true but it's worth
noting he doesn't have to pay taxes on
all those charitable donations
you may say this is a good thing if i
want to donate 50
to my church which i won't be taxed on
isn't that a freer
and more democratic form of giving than
whatever the government decides to do
with my taxes
and yes there's a certain allure to
millions of people freely choosing what
causes their money goes to before uncle
sam gets his grubby paws on it but with
someone like gates
a single man has withheld billions of
dollars in government revenue and
dispersed it according to his own will
sure you might not like where your tax
dollars are going to but at least
elected officials can be held
accountable when they allocate
20 million dollars to research cyborg
murder dolphins or maybe we love that
idea because that sounds super cool and
reelect everyone
involved again democracy now you won't
hear stuff like this from the conspiracy
sphere of the internet if you do it
might be a brief footnote and some
bigger evil or plan
but that's just the problem we don't
live in a crazy orwellian dystopia
we live in a very boring one and aside
from eroding trust in science or causing
measles outbreaks
this is another big threat from
conspiracy theories people waste their
powers of skepticism chasing phantoms
instead of scrutinizing the very flawed
reality we live in
even if you think bill gates is an angel
that every public health policy he
promotes as a home run that his money is
better spent by him than uncle sam
you should at least consider the idea as
espoused by famed poet kanye west that
no one man should have all that power
but what do you think wisecrack let us
know in the comments big thanks to our
patrons for supporting the channel and
our podcast
now that the bill and melinda gates
foundation will never give us money
maybe you should become a patron for two
dollars a month you'll get ad free
access to all of our videos
and if the comments are any indication
this is something many of you deeply
desire
and that's just the beginning higher
levels can get you access to our
patron-only discord where wisecrack
writers and hosts like me pop in to chat
with fans
if you're a fan of our channel you'll
really dig everything happening on our
patreon page
and we have some really amazing things
in the works that we'll be adding soon
so
why not get involved now ps bill if
you're watching this
we'll make a special tier just for you
for one thousand dollars a month
we'll let you say youfun media coverage
that vocally criticizes you
i'll also message you weekly
affirmations like forget the haters and
at least you're not mark zuckerberg and
all for less than one millionth of your
net worth
that's a bargain go to
patreon.comwisecrack and join today
and once you do message me on our
discord so you can tell me how to most
efficiently organize my bookshelf
i'll see you there later
[Music]
so
you